what have you seen from your perspective
I'm always interested when a doctor you
know pays attention to what I do and you
know this is not a professional
diagnosis no I'm not looking for one
either yeah
um well yeah I've been following
entrepreneurs and cars for a very long
time back when it was mostly about cars
and money uh I don't know much about
your personal life but I guess I could
kind of put some of the pieces together
by following that over the years and I
think that you went through a divorce
and I think that opened your eyes to
some of the realities of the let's say
family court system
some of the realities of single
Parenthood and dealing with the custody
of children
dealing with the distribution of your
assets and kind of building back up I
think you probably found the red pill
around the same time that I did and I
saw that really begin to infiltrate more
and more into your content and I could
see and I do this too in my own channel
I could see you kind of working things
out in your videos and I think like most
guys or maybe even all guys you went
through a period that was more
characterized as like the red pill rage
and I think you had to get that out of
your system and go through that because
I think when the scales are pulled from
your eyes it can be painful
but what I have noticed is in the last
few years I think that you have a much
more integrated more balanced approach
to the intersexual Dynamics and I think
you're really like coming into your own
in that sense like it feels really much
more integrated
yeah like there's always that shock I
suppose for guys when they stumble upon
content like this because it is
revealing it is exposing it is sometimes
painful it is
um sometimes obvious to us and we don't
want to accept it and I mean I I've I've
more or less pulled away as much as
possible from the manosphere that you
know aka the man of swamp as I like to
call it now and a lot of
um indulging or over indulging in which
what seems a lot of guys can and seem to
do and I noticed you put a video out on
your Channel about the red pill sort of
offering a little bit of guidance and
somewhat of a warning about it can you
can you talk about that a little bit
sure the way I framed that in that video
is that the red pill is almost like a
spiritual journey because like a
spiritual journey you probably won't end
up the same person at the end of it then
you started and so in that video I talk
about two different like spiritual
aphorisms that I think are very
appropriate to the red pill and one of
them has to do with Enlightenment and
there's this old joke about
Enlightenment that basically says you
want Enlightenment better not start
having started better finish
so I think kind of the vibe there is
this is a really big ask it's hard to
walk the path towards Enlightenment and
it probably means that you'll have to
lose
everything about the way your life used
to be
so it's an extraordinary sacrifice and
if you walk a little bit along and you
start to renounce your wealth and you
start to announce the world and you
start to announce relationships
and you stop there well that's the worst
of Both Worlds because you didn't
actually pass through that pronunciation
process into the joy of Enlightenment
you might as well have just stayed with
all of your toys and women and and your
comfortable little life so if you're
going to start this process you kind of
have to see it through
and
the metaphor that I extended to the red
pill is that a lot of people take the
red pill guys take the red pill usually
when they have a heartbreak or some sort
of rupture to their relationship and
they learn some things and it makes them
really upset and that's in my opinion
when they stop halfway towards
Enlightenment and I talk about how some
guys it sounds like the red pill is
caught in their throat like they've
swallowed it but they haven't really
digested it yet
and it's sort of like
they're like sputtering in Rage
sometimes and I you know I know what
that feels like it's not a good place to
stay
I've been angry enough in my life I
don't really enjoy experiencing that
emotion so I do what I can to learn my
lessons integrate and move forward
I see four distinct categories of like
sources of information is sort of Remedy
and and help guys sort of square away
their mindset when it comes to dealing
with relationships and women and that's
a big part of everybody's life like you
know you can pretend that it's not you
can you can unplug from it you can go
mgtow you know for a bit you know sort
of thing but I don't think that
any honest man can look at it and say
yeah it's it's just no longer going to
be a part of my life it's it's always
going to be a part of your life whether
you choose to engage in it or not but I
see watching human human behavior as one
aspect of it I see the red pill
um AKA you know the sources that come
from the man of swamp as
um you know a potential source of good
information I see evolutionary
psychology as a good potential source of
the information I also see psychology as
a good source of the information and I
think if you take
um from all of those areas and you sort
of blend it up into something that works
for you you put in a blender you blend
it up and you turn into a shake sort of
thing and you sort of you know take that
that's where you can sort of find the
freedom that you need to move forward in
life and operate in a frame or a mindset
or a mind frame that lets you put
yourself first what do you think about
that concept is that something that
you've looked at yeah I think that makes
sense to me I think that people should
keep an open mind
especially if they're having a problem
because if you're suffering from
something for several weeks several
months or even several years
if you could have solved it on your own
you would have solved it by now so the
solution is going to be located in a
place you haven't looked yet like by
definition
so if you have been stuck it really
behooves you to keep an open mind but to
never
trust anything unilaterally take
everything with a grain of salt test it
out in The Crucible of your own life if
it works keep it if it doesn't work
throw it out
this isn't about like
creating uh a cult it's not about
creating a following it's about trying
to help folks and the proof is in the
pudding so if if you listen to something
whether it's you me or somebody else and
it works because you've given it a the
old College try keep it and make it
yours
because a lot of this stuff that we talk
about we do it in our own way but it's
not entirely original either so it's our
own spin it's our own integrated
knowledge mixed with our own personal
experience that some people find
interesting or digestible and then they
can take it and make it their own that's
how it evolves yeah there's not a ton of
new ideas out there these days I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out